los diplomáticos dicen que las
negociaciones están en un momento
decisivo pero es un momento también
complicado ya que las líneas rojas y las
demandas de ambas partes deben ser
abordadas y gran dice que deben
levantarse las sanciones para lograr un
alivio económico es natural que la
república islámica irán espere que las
decisiones necesarias sean tomadas por
la otra parte especialmente en
washington la cuestión del beneficio
económico de la república islámica por
el levantamiento de las sanciones es muy
esencial y en la línea roja de irán con
respecto a la cuestión del levantamiento
de las sanciones hay incertidumbre sobre
si las sanciones se levantarían de una
vez o por etapas además otra demanda
clave de iran es obtener garantías para
que el acuerdo se mantenga y para evitar
que la próxima administración de eeuu se
retire de este como ya lo hizo el
presidente de trump en 2018 por su parte
eeuu exige la detención del
enriquecimiento de uranio de irán y
también a revertir sus capacidades irán
dice no tener intención de construir
armas nucleares pero los expertos
aseguran que tiene la capacidad de
hacerlo en unas semanas israel se
muestra escéptico ante un posible
acuerdo
en las últimas semanas precisamente
durante las negociaciones irán ha
aumentado sus agresiones y ha recurrido
repetidamente al terrorismo en la región
como todos ustedes han visto así es como
se llevan a cabo las negociaciones al
estilo de teherán theron una
preocupación que también comparten otras
potencias occidentales y por eso la
urgencia para zanjar el acuerdo